all right people this is breaking news
today I have been told to sit down I was
given a piece of paper in front of me
which I have not looked at yet it's
upside down I was given a pen and I was
told that Brock over there is going to
read 15 things to me I don't know what
they are I have no context for any of
this you're going to just read 15 things
for me I will look in the camera maybe
I'll make a little motion or something
as you read them as I react and then I'm
going to order these things from best
tours that's what we're doing here today
all right Brock take it away okay rank
these cities from best to worst
New York City
Los Angeles
Chicago
San Francisco Austin
Nashville Miami Baltimore Portland
Seattle St Louis Washington DC and
Damascus Syria
I don't know if you caught what was
happening there for the first three I
kind of played along and then I just
moved my head sort of in random ways for
the rest of it okay so can I flip this
over now and now I'm going to flip them
or flip this over okay so now I have to
rank these cities from best to worst I
mean worst by far San Francisco just too
damned easy like that's that's easy
like I would love to spend the weekend
in Damascus Syria before going to San
Francisco San Francisco is absolutely
the worst for sure uh
Portland OR Seattle probably has to be
the next worst Seattle is a real
hole
Coral is pretty bad but I love those
early Blazers so I'm going to give a
little love to Portland right now oh
Connor's from Seattle oh and I'm gonna
dump on let me see Baltimore is pretty
bad
you guys didn't put oh you did put
Washington DC the Cesspool of DC
um
cattle's bad man but Chicago people get
killed in here you know what let's do
this wait how many people were shot in
Chicago this past week I know we did
another show this week it was like 73
people right yeah in honor of those 73
Chicago Bears you're going number two
which is a damn shame I mean Windy City
you know should be good there great
sense of humor the people in Chicago I
guess you have to have Seattle we're
going is number three
uh and Portland I can't push you that
far
off this disastrous list yeah Portland's
got to go right there but I'm fine on a
Portland Seattle swap you're both stupid
uh in that direction oh by the way I'm
doing this from worst to best
which is an interesting way I guess to
do this instead of the other way around
that's on you again I've never been to
Damascus but I feel like they have olive
oil
shrapnel
um
it was in St Louis a couple times it's
pretty pretty depressed
um well Baltimore is a oh all right
Baltimore Baltimore and with that's all
with due respect to the aquarium in
Baltimore which I haven't been to in 20
years but about 20 years ago I was there
it was pretty good but Baltimore is a
dumped I mean Washington DC let's just
let's just throw it there it's it's just
you know a wretched Hive of scum and
villainy St Louis I I don't know enough
about the specifics of St Louis but I
was there a couple times and it wasn't
great St Louis is actually the murder
capital of the world St Louis is the
murder cat well take that Chicago
[Applause]
we got something nice
um
all right we're getting into like the
good area now so
um
we got let's see
well Miami's obviously going to go up
high Nashville is a great town I don't
love Austin and I think it's I think
it's pretty dumpy and even the people in
Austin when they say they love Austin
they mean they live in the suburbs of
Austin
quiet sure is a hot one today huh nobody
really likes it that much uh
you know what though if I had to we're
gonna put Damascus Syria next
because the others were starting to
venture into like sane territory right
so we'll do uh Damascus Syria then then
we'll do Austin Texas I feel like the
hipsters are gonna be pissed at me on
that one I'm giving love here just
because I've lived there to Los Angeles
and New York uh Los Angeles
dumb hell hole filled with the worst
people ever so we'll put Los Angeles
there then New York City obviously and
then really the big two it's Nashville
or Miami I mean this is pretty freaking
obvious we're going naturally number two
and Miami is the best city in these
United States of America fact check that